MURAT YENER: One of the biggest
UI changes coming to Android Q
is gestural navigation.
You may have already seen
various gestures for navigation
on some of our
partners' devices.
Android Q is supporting a
new out-of-the-box navigation
experience.
Navigation gestures
are supported
as a new mode, separate from
the traditional three-button
experience in the
bottom nav bar.
This lets your app
use the entire screen,
which provides a more
immersive display experience.
Android Q has gestures for
going home and going back.
Swiping up from the
bottom edge takes the user
to the home screen.
Swiping inwards anywhere
on the left or right just
takes the user back to
the previous screen.
With these two
gestures, your app
can take advantage of the
valuable screen real estate
on the bottom of the display.
However, if your app uses
gestures or has controls
in the system gesture areas,
it might create conflict
with the system-wide gestures.
For example, if your
app relies on gestures
for sliders or draggable items
in any of the system gesture
areas, your users
might accidentally
trigger a navigation gesture.
This results in a broken
experience in your app.
There are two gestural conflicts
your app might encounter.
The first conflict
is with the swipe
up gesture on the bottom
edge of the screen,
which takes the user
to the home screen.
You should avoid having
any critical controls rely
on vertical swipe gesture in
the bottom parts of your app
because the home
gesture is designed
to be a reliable escape
mechanism for users
and will always get
priority for touch events.
Examples of UI conflicts
with the home gesture
are bottom draggable
sheets or other swipe
up to perform actions.
To steer clear of the
bottom swipe conflict,
we edit WindowInsets.get
MandatoryGestureInsets,
which returns all swipe
recognition thresholds
for the device.
Using this information, apps
can shift conflicting content
from the edges of the screen.
The second conflict is
with the H swipe gesture,
which takes the user back.
The system back gesture
occupies the entire length
of the left and
right screen edges,
so apps should make sure
that key touch and motion
functionality isn't stolen
by system back gesture.
Examples of interaction
conflicts with the back gesture
include drawers,
sliders, sheets,
and other controls
which require a swipe
or drag to perform an action.
In order to handle touch events
at the edges of the screen,
apps can tell the
system which areas
they need to exclude
from the back gesture
with the new gesture
exclusion rect
API in Q. If back gesture
interferes with your app
controls, use the
gesture exclusion rect
API to create gesture exclusion
zones for the controls that
might be affected.
On the other hand, do not
disable the back gesture
by creating a gesture
exclusion zone which spans
entire edge of the screen.
This creates a broken,
non-consistent behavior
with the system and other apps.
The new API is a part
of the View class, which
expects a list of rect
objects that represent
gesture exclusion zones.
This API lets your app
intercept horizontal swipes
only between the desired areas.
The gesture exclusion
rects API call
should be performed in
the onLayout or onDraw
methods of the view, as
shown in this example.
DrawerLayout and
SeekBar components
already have this
opt-out behavior
built in, so no
additional work is needed,
other than updating the
jetPack dependencies
and/or build against the
new SDK, respectively.
And that's it.
To ensure the best
user experience,
make sure the
gestures in your app
do not conflict with the
system-wide gestures.
If they do, use system
gesture exclusion rects
API to fix any problems
before targeting
your app to Android Q.
If you're interested
in gestural navigation,
make sure you also watch the
edge-to-edge dev bite, which
is linked in the notes below.
Thank you for watching.
Make sure to subscribe to the
channel for more awsome Android
videos.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]